hey what is up everybody it Briggs your
face I can see your face suddenly
welcome to another episode of rent cafe
episode 90 I believe in this one we're
going to be going on all out in an
all-out rifle war try not to get
triggered last week with it a shounen
wife award have turned into a mess it
was an absolute mess people got mad at
each other
it was crazy so I promised that I would
make a brand new bracket all the choices
picked by myself and I did done that and
it's not limited to just show them
either so we're gonna be diving deep I
got Briggs from all the anime joining me
what's up bro what's up man good to be
back can't promise that I won't get
triggered but oh I don't look like fours
at least this time there's only a few of
us asunder was five and it was and we
have Jordan the anime dude joining us
because he is a big connoisseur of anime
waifu's he made a video recently about
the summer dress and the importance of
summer dresses and waifu's so link to
his channel in the description as well
as Briggs's so mana maker
thanks for having me absolutely a
pleasure also if you want to see the
bracket the link is in the description
to the Twitter post where the bracket is
up hangouts doesn't really allow you to
put it up and it's the resolution is not
good enough for us to like show you on
the phone or whatever so you know you're
gonna have to bear with them but we will
say it we will say who the waifu's are
as we go you know as the stream goes on
so you will be able to tell also big
another announcement before we get
started you guys might know that we did
that create your own my hero academia
character challenge a few weeks ago and
it was a huge success and character
design the winning character design was
just revealed who's already did an
amazing job for syncro designed by
gravity falls
it's so sick it's so sick everybody
looks so cool man I know I was like
blown away and the gravity falls the
Creator was also blown away and so yeah
it's awesome and it was the contest was
so successful over a thousand entries
that we decided to do some kind of
contest every month if we
the next contest we're gonna be doing
that's gonna be closing in two weeks so
for starting today by closing two weeks
is gonna be a create your own attack on
Titan character challenge in particular
creating your own new Titan shifter so
if you read the manga you know what a
Titan shifters are but pretend that
there's another one and you can create
it determine what its powers are what it
looks like what the backstory of the
userupp is all of that is going to be
available for you link in the
description to our Twitter the pinned
post is the announcement for this
contest so you can start your entries
today 200 words maximum and then
probably next month will go back to
again doing another mighty rough edenia
character but I just want to switch it
up I don't want to get it too repetitive
but yeah it's gotta be fun and again
huzzah maddie is going to bring the
winning design to life just like he did
with the previous one and we're right
now in talks with this place calm for
them to sponsor the contest and send the
winning design as a huge art picture a
physical art picture to the winner and
to myself so I can showcase it to you
guys so if we can make that happen it's
gonna be awesome even better
and yeah so exciting stuff guys exciting
stuff oh yeah I think we make a fake
account and like cuz you Animax the one
who goes through it and i'm gonna like a
submit one lo hee see if I can make it
in alright we'll do it do I look forward
to that and let me just I'm gonna try to
show you on the phone the winning entry
I don't know how well you can see that
but that is synchro it's her power is to
jump into electronic devices or pull
someone else into them so she's got a
bunch of code trying to Isis all around
her
I think the anime would be better if
this character was added to the series
no yeah I will be sick it'll be a great
character design but also like the
thought behind like her backstory and
her actual quirk is amazing yeah
absolutely awesome designed and like I
said I really enjoyed going through like
a thousand submissions I want to do that
again this month next month because it's
just so much fun encouraging you guys
support
an artist getting you you know your
designs brought to life I think it's
very very cool house their own in the
Chad doing are you guys ready for this
wife of war I'm good friends with these
guys I hope we will still be good
friends after this stream ends I who I
know no promises or not friends until
the stream is over yeah
Briggs is always like enemy dudes one of
my closest friends but not now not until
this stream is over everybody's RAM
who's Jordan oh don't go there but
thankfully Ram is not on this list
because she would terribly lose yeah I'm
already kind of little salty about Anna
Mac picking the list cuz some of these
choices and some of the people left out
well the thing is like we did it last
week - it's impossible there's too many
good white foods right this time like if
you look over the top right it's like
bull more versus out Winry and actually
a lot of people be prefer like Hawkeye
versus like Android 17 or 18 whatever
number it is but we already do that last
week so we got changed it up can't be
the same things are picking this the
rules were you can repeat the sick the
same character from last week and you
can't repeat more than one character
from an anime so that's what we're doing
otherwise you could have like four or
five wife loose just from coal Geass
right so that's what we're switching it
we have to have some ground rules
otherwise this is gonna get too crazy I
think the list is pretty good I'm
excited I say we jump into it voice and
by the way some people are asking asking
where is Knox did he die he's actually
alive but he's out of town attending a
lord - eagle convention so he will be
indisposed for the next week but he'll
be back hopefully maybe maybe he is
serving the glory of Lord we go in one
way or another but let's start this
match up everybody first we have albedo
from overlord versus he Mikoto --ga from
my hero academia by the way some of
these were recommended by you guys on
Twitter and these two I paired up
together because they are some of our
favorite yandere in anime also currently
airing anime so very
hyped-up so yeah this is gonna be a good
one guys who wants to start it off Chad
feel free to weigh in as well
I think Alberto is the best DeAndre cuz
like mostly Andres I always have
something my heart like I hate them in
some way because they're crazy [ __ ]
right but I don't think I hate Alberto
in any way because at the end of the day
like I think it's like she's not she
doesn't have her own best interest in
her mind which like something Andria's
do her if her best interest is always
the best interest of her her love is
gone yeah this one's kinda it's kind of
rough but toga is the type that if she
loves you enough she's probably gonna
kill you and how what's her name again
the one from overlord how beldo she's a
type that if she loves you enough she's
gonna rape you so it's like what what
what would we prefer which would you
prefer
yeah I'm have to go without Beto to and
that would be also my choice because
because
Tolga is interesting yeah but she is if
I'm really under she's like oh I love
staney I want to eat staney and become
him and [ __ ] you know so she's the two
different types are you under you have a
younger and that's like so crazy she
wants to kill you and like eat you so
that she can be with you forever boy and
you have like I under that would kill
for you and I feel like Alberto is the
younger that would feel for you toga is
the under you can't you know trust to
not murder you in your sleep
it's kind of like the fouseytube
you know and you're Drake so you don't
know what's gonna happen but uh yeah I'm
definitely going with Alberto I love her
I love when she just like in the was
that in the this season at the end of
last season uh trouble when she like
just jumps on on irons that was season
three okay so beginning of season three
yes oh man that was that was like that's
the cutting under I wanna that's what
I'm like eyes bro eyes yeah you are you
happy that I finally got into overlord
yes no not my favorite but it's good
it's elevated
is is really good world building really
good strategy involved and I love this
character I'm gonna have to make some
videos on it because I really people
have been asking me and I want to do it
the only thing when Overlord is it
focuses too much on side stories that
are not necessarily that interesting
yeah like that's the big problem with it
but still enjoyable and yeah also albedo
guys I think we all have to agree in the
chat that albedo is the more developed
character oh yeah
plot is very thick with her well toga
struggle just against southern my hero
academia girls I know she's popular but
I don't know it's it's kind of unfair
matchup yeah well I mean you know I I
took some popular and interesting young
today and I think it's a fair matchup
there are certain people here who would
vote for toga is just happened to be
that the three of us are men of culture
yeah we're men of culture
why don't we Steven donated five bucks
to say damn and I'm late again we
started the stream words of wisdom for
when I catch up don't debate wife who's
with your friends it usually doesn't end
well I mean so far we're all on the same
page but if I have any advice for you
yeah well so far what we did so far so
good and appreciate of course the
donation all the donations and stuff
that come through Ren cafe on this
channel from now on are definitely going
to go to supporting the artists for the
contest so that we can pay pro artists
to make contest stuff so keep that in
mind guys
and let's go on to number two albedo has
won the first round
what am I like top five wife was of all
time by the way so I didn't want to
really get into it cuz togas cool and
everything but like now we have an
interesting matchup zero two from
darling in the Franks and c2 from Code
Geass both are interesting characters
with a tragic past who kind of swooped
in and completely changed the main
character's life and kind of like push
him to do things that he could ever have
done before I feel like
very uninteresting matchup here what do
you guys think I think it's gonna be a
biased matchup could be I know we got
some code yes fanboys here okay I think
0-2 is an awesome character and a top to
your waifu myself so who would you vote
for Anna Mac okay well in the chat we
see like three zero twos and everyone
else say c2 but personally like I said I
love 0-2 I think she's a very
interesting character interesting past
quirky and kind of pushes the boundaries
of that society same thing with with c2
like she just shows up she's completely
quirky she doesn't fit in it's because
she's you know so many years old and she
seems so much both are very attractive
obviously both are have just like had
that mystery factor right just that
mystery factor oh don't tell me you're
actually thinking about this I am man
I'm seriously thinking about it because
they're I think they're both like sane
to your wife you don't agree I don't I
mean I've only seen all right granddad
I've only seen about half of darling in
the Franks so that might skew it just a
bit but my god c2 or at least in my
opinion is the number one waifu of all
time and you're telling me that don't
give a what you'll do why do you love so
much about c2 what makes her special as
always so just the way she carries
herself probably because of all the
years of experience she said she's so
composed and mature with how she handles
every event in the show but she still
has those like cute little quirky
characteristics like she loves pizza and
uh and uh she could be immature and get
jealous at times but for the most part I
just love how she carries herself and
how knowledgeable she is okay so but
also remember and I want everyone in the
chat remember this as well you have to
when we're talking about waifu you have
to be like if i'm married to this woman
she's gonna be a good wife who to me so
do you think c2 would be a good wife
would you be like i'm doing my own thing
[ __ ] you Jordan
not be a perfect weapon you're
automatically gonna fall in love with
her
right based on her her Geass ability
right I feel like it doesn't work
anymore because she can't work anymore
I'm not as knowledgeable about coke yes
as you guys well welcome plug I'd he got
through with ms0 Jeff Leon has anyone
running in the flanks I watch like two
episodes and c2 is pretty hot actually
they're both pretty hot but well so I
might have missed something in the
second half of darling in the Franks cuz
I've only seen half like I said but 0-2
was interesting but she wasn't oh she
didn't seem quite as deep or mature or
anything she was just kind of the well
she is one girl that would go do her own
thing and like you said nobody was gonna
tell her it's like she'd follow any
orders she just I don't know she is much
younger by the way much younger 0:02 is
like late teens
whereas c2 is hundreds of years old
so that is that phone the case the other
thing she she just seemed a little bit
immature to me at times but I haven't
it's like I said I haven't seen the
whole thing so it's kind of hard to
judge
she seemed solid and based on what I
have seen but I think the chat is are
you looking for Oh see - nope no
question yeah we have one see - Briggs
and you well I will overall I mean it is
a toss-up for me but I think c2 just has
more of a legacy because Cody s is older
and like more episodes we know more
about her so I will pick c2 but I
definitely think that 0-2 is a good
competitor here awesome I wanted to try
to force you guys to make the decision I
pretty I was pretty confident you guys
are both in the pixie - this cuz I'm not
like I like this like this specific
matchup not great for me personally I
only really know about c2 at least you
guys know more about both of them well I
feel like when I first saw darling in
Frank's like my initial thoughts were
hey this girl is kind of similar to C -
yeah if anything no I'd be a girl that's
up there with her as far as a wife you
list and stuff but as the series went on
she's kind of
a little bit for me where I guess she
stayed up there for an iMac but I mean
the serious dropped off but I think her
as a wife was different
yeah yeah but okay zero two wins so next
match was a milkmaid oh I see - wait
wait what next Metro is gonna be albedo
vs. Yuto that's gonna be [ __ ] Roth
Jordan oh thank you
that can be hard but I feel yeah you're
gonna fight over this one people are
freaking out in the chat about Ram lore
like one dude is it's like hey calm down
I suck we said we're gonna have more of
these tournaments and who you talking
about
Ben every quality waifu into one bracket
and either way ram wouldn't make it cut
because amelia is best girl but actually
i do want to make one bracket myself
where i like start off with the first
round is two characters from the same
series i think would be interesting to
debate like blue ram versus amelia
Android 17 versus Bulma or like Hawkeye
versus winner II like kind of yeah true
and you know what we would have to
actually we would have to literally kind
of do five people probably because it's
me and you are in the same and it's
three then obviously Amelia's gonna win
so we're gonna have to again why be
chaos though to be fair same series to
be the point of rank of a chaos is good
yeah next we have albedo and c2 making
it into the next round
respect to our girls toga and 0-2 next
round is the Battle of the tsundere
taiga aisaka from toradora versus rin
tohsaka from fate/stay night unlimited
blade works that was the one I heard him
don't you really like taiga from what I
remember yeah I liked Toradora as a
series and tygo is probably one of the
first Sundari like true Sundari is I was
ever really introduced to but I wasn't
really that big on her as a character
but at the same time I don't know much
about the Rin that she's up against I
haven't seen much of the Fate series so
her Rin from unlimited blade works gets
a lot more like I guess airtime I felt
the same way like I didn't really feel
too strongly about taiga I thought you
liked her that's why I kind of went
towards that but ya know I'm voting for
Rin well can you guys tell me a little
bit about ran because I know I don't
know too much powerful made love super
cute okay yeah so he has a lot of cinder
a characteristic I think she's a
stronger character than the protagonist
of the series to be honest without a
[ __ ] his name is I mean I was [ __ ] but
so this is interesting because taiga I
remember she has a you know a difficult
childhood with her parents having issues
with her parents and all this other
stuff which is one of the reasons why
she acts out an axe aggressive so she is
a two minute that actually has a reason
why she's assumed that I ran as well
like her she is stuck in this family
this magical family that's part of these
battles constantly and like she loses
members of her family because of ed and
stuff so I think again it why pick them
is because I feel like they these
characters do me the same vibe they are
some that is on the outside but have a
very you know sensitive inner core that
develops as the anime goes on and they
both have difficulties in their past
that they had to overcome yeah man and
and both of them are fan favorites and
and the chat is pretty split to be
honest so that's interesting I just saw
somebody described her as a suitor a
Hermione and that's kind of appealing
but I don't know I don't like I said I
haven't really been introduced to her
enough to feel too confident in my and
my vote like from what I remember about
taiga like I think she was a what
well-written character by never overly
liked her well-written I like I had it
wasn't I had no reason to dislike Grimm
and Rin in every way in anyway yeah but
the thing with taiga is she can be
overly aggressive at times like
physically whereas not necessarily
physically she can just be kind of like
that's whatever I don't care
I thought I'd like to read anything Baca
yeah at least that's that's what I
remember I don't think I don't think
Wren was like physically abusive am i
right yeah no I'd say Tyga I don't know
if I ever found her like physically
attractive or anything and if I remember
correctly she punched out the main
character in like episode 1 yes don't
you look really kick your ass I do have
a girl I can kick my ass but I don't
know you don't wanna be married to her
attracted to like qualities at all
personally so then he wouldn't be a fair
fight because I don't just be like Rin
I'm trying to get me some looks then
then you're trying to as much as we can
go on personality but in the end you
know we are all biased I'm gonna go with
Tiger then just cuz I don't know the
other girl very much at all the caster's
I'm still good character tried to kill
Shiro once and Kaster should know about
fate the bettors cast it yeah so we have
taiga we have rent and I'm gonna have to
go for Rin again is a very cool and
memorable character and a fan favorite
and some of her facial expressions are
like classic memes but Rin to me is just
the better waifu character mm-hmm
alright look from what caster just said
I'm choosing between a girl that can
kick my ass and a girl that's gonna try
to kill me so though the background
though it's in phase all of this
tournament for like basically like it's
basically Hunger Games magical right for
the Holy Grail exactly and so I think in
the beginning maybe Britain tried to
kill em eeeh or Shiro whatever his name
is and but towards the end I feel like
they really warmed out towards each
other I I shipped them I shipped them oh
do i ship saber with him more though I
like Anna Anna mattress left I'm kind of
ramble here a little bit here I just
have to get prepared for the next round
guys know that a darkness body pillow
everybody got that that's funny right
darkness
darkus is another top five white food
lorry you guys all get to see the other
side because you don't deserve it
alright so next round everybody its
darkness from kono Suba wait who in the
last round versus scarlet yeah it's like
in my bracket I would make out put
darkness against mega mean right and
that darkness would obviously win of
course of Paris daughter look looking
dark bro just just she's an actually
developed character unlike mega mega
means just one big egg or no more ways
that one we see some of it mega means
backstory but I don't know
she had a rivalry without one other girl
and she kind of was kind of like a dick
to her and that's it oh she also like
struggled to get food and everything but
some people in the chat are saying
because they don't like ferret that dark
Verger sucks I personally liked her she
was my top waifu pig in CONUS up in
fairy tale she's like darkness they're
both like fighters they're tough eyes a
bit more accurate when it comes to sword
fighting than darkness but I think both
of them are good wife is I definitely
think that Ursa is good and I don't even
mind Lucy personally I know a lot of
people hate her but yeah so you guys
know fairy tale right so yeah what do
you think yeah I'm gonna go the theory
not a hundred percent caught up in fairy
tale but I've seen more than enough to
know that my phone is going towards
there's a scarlet just cuz I love her
ability and I mean she's pretty [ __ ]
hot oh dang with that I don't know I've
seen over well over a hundred episodes
of Fairy Tail and I'm gonna be honest
I'm not that big of a fan of it but at
the same time out of what I have seen
airs it was definitely one of my
favorite characters she was brilliant
yeah fairy tale but I liked her as a
character I enjoyed her fights more than
Nazis fights
mm-hmm all like every fighters that got
better
well not sue for my biggest complaint
with fairytales like he knew he would
learn these new techniques or like
figure out a way to defeat opponent and
then it's like he completely forgot
everything and in his next battle right
while Ursa I feel like she would always
her battle her battles you would use her
her ability really like really smartly
she's super skilled in combat and like
she would find a way to defeat her
opponent and it's not like the next
fight she'd forget all that she'd use
that end more just there in combat
though her her backstory was so
endearing to me yeah it was sold and we
do you have you seen kono Suba I have
like three times are you voting for Ursa
no yeah so my reason why I love darkness
and have to go with her is that a she's
freaking amazingly hot be she's
hilarious and yeah people say oh she's a
masochist which is kind of like
problematic if you want to like a
faithful wife ooh life ooh however
darkness is actually a virgin in the
anime and she doesn't even though she's
a masochist and stuff she has a strong
code of honor like she's a very as a
knight she has a strong code of honor
and she would never I feel betray her
husband so she wouldn't be kinky but
only for her husband so I feel like
that's a bonus of anything not to
mention that la latina a que darkness is
also from a really wealthy noble family
so you would be getting that dowry boy
dowry yes there's all the reasons that
you just said but then there's also you
just got to consider oh yeah she's I
don't know I don't know how to word it
she's messed up as a person as a
character all the girls in Kona super
very flawed but that also makes her a
little bit more realistic yeah whenever
I think about it I don't know it makes
her a very funny character I don't know
if I'd she's waifu for me trying how to
word it
because darkness is not my favorite
color Supergirl but there's something
that all the conus super girls have that
just makes them it's like a situational
like a sitcom so I don't know they just
you could see yourself getting along
with them every day and every day life
without it being too abnormal yeah like
I felt in called a tsuba like darkness
is my favorite because aqua is so like
dumb and like egotistical but mega mean
to me has no character development like
no reason for me to care about her she
likes explosions big whoop and you know
like I don't care
aqua does get personality but it's not
necessarily kind of personal you want
for a wife Lola should watch these are
freaking darkness really gets that
personality in a way that I would want
for a wife yeah I can understand that
so he voted for dark diner Mac you voted
for darkness right oh yeah of course I
voted for Ursa and it's all up to Jordan
the my would you vote for us are you Oh
see I miss Bracken Briggs but [ __ ] you I
can describe why I like Ayers a better
but I don't know I still feel like
darkness is just it's something
undescribable she's just up there above
hares uh yes feed it or Jordan feed into
it animate dude I don't know how to
describe it it's just yeah I think it
might have been a power of the body
pillar darkest and albedo are both in
like my top five did I have swords by me
[ __ ] or despondent yeah whatever
breaks top five wife who's definitely
not harissa let's do this next round we
have where are we okay
Bulma from Dragon Ball vs. Winry from
Full Metal Alchemist by the way the what
was the name of the dude that was on
last rank of fate that was like bull my
is best girl Bulma needs to be on here I
love Bulma wasn't remember is Natasha
was a job job if Joshua Toback yeah
brother I think it was said and he was
like yo we need Bolin because she wasn't
on the bracket we had Android 18 in last
week's
a bracket for Dragonball but not Bulma
so he really wanted Bulma in there we
have boma here now and whinnery and
again both characters that strike me as
simply give me a similar vibe like
they're both really really smart women
they're inventors they are crucial for
the plot because they help the main
characters achieve what they need to
achieve they both have an attitude they
don't take [ __ ] they're you know they'll
smack you if you're being dumb so it's
like I feel like both of these are
quality choices and especially I mean
with when Rishi definitely kind of liked
gets ed to cozy up to her and to kind of
develop because of her but Vegeta tames
Bulma I mean Bulma tames Vegeta that's
pretty freakin crazy
which seems impossible yeah like she God
Vegeta mr. Prince of all Saiyans to
become a caring family like man and a
father and stuff I I love that all right
so the distinction on this one like
something that I think needs to be
clarified before we go into any further
discussion is which boma are we talking
about are we talking about the old
school like Dragon Ball Bulma that was
like a probably more of a breath in aqua
from kono Suba or what whole character
and advancements overall it's you know
difficult though cuz I like older boma
I like the boma that's like I don't know
like that's already married to Vegeta
and stuff like I feel like she's a good
wife to him good mother creator also
someone mentioned the chat she can also
be annoying sometimes Bulma like to
forward and to like aggressive but when
we can - right like she's been known to
you know smack head up a few times
especially when he messes up his her
modifications and stuff so I mean in
that sense you can say both of them have
that sort of spark no that's just
because winter cares when were he's
doing it at like the goodness of her
heart like for the better interest of
allen-head
whereas bomas just like a B word for the
early Dragonball and early DBZ well
maybe not DBZ III think I'm thinking of
now in Super as well because I think we
have to count it be counting her whole
progression and I feel like in Super
she's definitely a very quality wife who
like she's quirky she's kind of like
doing her oh I'm not old thing but like
she's here on planet earth uh Namek like
way she treated Crillon in them like I
don't know if I could deal with that
24/7 yeah so they maintain ed that he
can be a handful but I feel like Winry
can - I don't know what what do you
think bricks I mean when reads one of my
favorite wife is she's just such a
caring and loving individual and I think
the fact that I'm actually struggling
right now to make a decision but so like
that just shows how good of a character
Bluma is even her entire progression
because you get to see her change as a
person like she goes from like a whiny
little kid and Dragon Ball kind of a
little bit annoying and then she slowly
progresses and she came Vegeta I think
she's actually had a like a good impact
on both Vegeta and Goku yeah well at the
end of the day I think I'm gonna have to
vote for Winry she's one of my favorite
wife who's personally I think you might
have to have less of an impact on the
series in Bulma but like also Dragon
Ball Z's like a million episodes versus
Full Metal Alchemist
only like 6000 I mean I love wintry to
us a character but I I'm gonna go for
ball not just because I'm partial to
Mill's
but also the whole like I love the
development that Vegeta goes through
from becoming the villain to becoming a
family man and you know Bulma basically
like yeah he he he still has his pride
but sometimes Bulma can give it better
and like Vegeta you know take care of
kids so yeah I'm gonna go with bullying
but obviously a close call for me yeah I
think when you just feel like a better
person to me you two gotta quit doing
this to me I don't know yeah I want to
leave this up to anime dudes that he has
to make the final call and feel bad
about it that's my goal
Oh cricket man yeah I don't know I don't
know I'm like I'm at a loss because like
I said it's hard to go with the it's
hard to go against like milf Bulma like
end of the gene or Dragon Ball super
boma and like ended DBZ but at the same
time when Drees top tier yeah Michaels
and we're my goal here was to have a all
the top tiers you know nothing that
there's not more there's of course more
but my goal was for all the pigs to be
pretty talked here so you know I can't
blame you for that I think I'm gonna go
with Bulma
just because with all the character
analysis I end up doing you got a love
character development and she starts out
so unlikable and polarizing but like I
said she does develop into that
character that can actually compete
against Winry in this type of bracket
whereas I
Winry we don't see quite as much
development on her part she's just
worrying about ed now the whole time
when Rees a solid girl from like five
until the end of the series like her
entire developing like she'd even need
to develop that's how good of a person's
is yes and then her character was just
her learning to forgive scar yeah after
she found out happened to her parents
but like it was like a brief moment in
the middle of the series and I don't
know maybe it's nostalgia I think I'm
gonna go with boma
okay bolo wins our boy long king should
be fighting bull my moves on but when we
of course is class class act and like I
said all of these girls should be class
I that's that's why I picked them so you
know you can't can't get mad at that now
we have Yoko lit nur from Gurren Lagann
versus Adina Yelich from assassination
classroom also known as Beach Sun by the
Japanese who can't probably pronounce
Serbian names that's right you Dina is
like the only Serbian significant
character in anime and that's why I love
her
and ya know gonna vote for Yoko he's
freakin amazingly hot
and GUI logon is my favorite anime of
all time so this is great for me great I
don't know who I want to go for I'm just
kidding I'm voting for Gurren Lagann
best girl well see this is why I would
like I like yoga as a character a lot
but I don't know if she's the best wife
I mean she is a good waifu unless you
think that she's like a black widow
because every guy she hook ups hooks up
with and dies in the same episode so
that's a bit of a problem but if we do
look at Yoko's character overall she
goes from you know being a girl
struggling to survive in a horrible
world and actually you know fighting to
survive I'm not laying back and taking
it like many people to you know a class
a warrior just you know fighting with up
there with everyone to them becoming a
teacher and you know teaching people
with arena we have a former assassin who
joins the school as a teacher as well to
teach assassination to the students she
is very tough on the outside where you
think like the ocean they call her [ __ ]
son she's like [ __ ] you all you know
this stuff but then she really warms up
to the other teacher dude as the series
goes on and like she you really see her
that she has like a very warm interior
that she hides because of her traumatic
childhood and war and that actually and
how she became a assassin and all that
type of stuff so in terms of waifu I
have to go with Adina I have to go with
her because she is obviously both are
extremely hot let's just no I think you
just have a thing for blondes thing I
don't I don't actually I don't in real
life like I never had a blonde
girlfriend probably no I did but not
it's funny I think I have a thing for
blondes and yet I voted for two
red-haired girls virtually honest yeah
because what I'm saying I just think you
know like the way she develops as a
character is like she would be a good
wife you know well their development
burns off and are you like it rough but
then she would be the wife whereas with
Yoko we don't know what she would be
like
relationship because unfortunately they
never get to develop anything suppose
they all die I feel like I don't like
Irina enough like she was really
annoying for a lot of the series for me
like towards the end I like there he
developed by the other day like I could
still see that [ __ ] in her bed
I haven't seen enough of a assassination
classroom like I saw enough to get
introduced to her but I haven't really
seen her develop bastard yeah bastard
anime dude you can't build it I feel I
should only develop this you fell in
love you can't do my girl you never
liked that because you haven't seen the
show like why I'd like it's a great show
anime can wait go on marathon we're
putting reg Rafael on hold we can't I
think I mean is a little bit too
superficial for me I will say though
like even though every guy that ends up
being with Yoko dies like that day I
feel like Yoga is such a top tier why
fear that like worth it you get one
day's all you need like jokes
these days I trust her here are the kids
or do whatever she wants to do but that
one day is all I need yeah it's like and
also you're not in the gurren lagaan
world sorry go ahead
no I'm saying you can't handle her for
more than a day so okay so we have to
for your Co correct yeah yeah yeah so I
can't really complain like I said all of
these are talk to your wife is my mind
so I can't complain for Yoko going
through my mobile Serena but let's do
this let's move on so in the next
bracket we're gonna have Bulma versus
Yoko and now we have Rukia from Bleach
versus mucky sickly sue okay Christina
from steins gate these two give me a
similar wire vibe that's why I wanted
them they're similar five alright I'm
about to say something that will
probably make you both hate me already
why but I have not seen steins gate yet
what the [ __ ] what that's totally
alright I know it is in the you can only
see something for the first time once so
I've been saving it
dude how how didn't I know that either I
feel like I've told you that mean spooks
like you guys are acting like it's like
horrible secrets dude I know like it's
something I don't like to admit but I
just I haven't seen it yet I don't I
think I have a really big weakness for
cinder is because I'm voting for Mika
say Kurisu without a doubt in my mind oh
if you two split it on me this time I
don't know what I'm gonna do so well
then you can go with Rukia since you
haven't seen sighs and then you guys are
splitting it for me yeah I'm gonna go
through Kia yeah better not [ __ ] this up
adam ak well you know what I am NOT a
super huge fan of Maki say as much as
other people are like I feel like yeah
she's a good two minutes she's a good
caring about chick she would not be my
top ten wife was at all however I will
still vote for her over but who Kia just
because I feel like her storyline to me
is more compelling and oak of his
feelings for her and how that develops
then the bleach stories so Maki said for
the win and with that we go to the final
matchup of round one we have faith
Valentine from Cowboy Bebop a girl that
can kick your ass versus another girl
that can kick your ass
Saeko from high school of the day boys
the hard-on yeah oh sure Dean I know
you're doing not really I feel like Faye
Valentine was one of those girls before
I watched a Cowboy Bebop
I thought she was gonna be a talk to
your waifu and then i watched it and at
the very beginning I was like damn she's
a gold digger she's terrible with money
like he seems like a girl I would not
get along with at all
but then by the end you can't like you
can't help but to be attached to her so
yes that's the thing she's a she's a
really and that's why I good in her
because you know on the surface I will
definitely agree with you
that PHA is not the ideal wife like
she's a gambler she does her own thing
she'll just like yeah she doesn't care
she she acts like she doesn't need you
and stuff and yet there's something
about her man you know like we get her
backstory and then we get her like
relationship with everyone on board the
ship and with spike and then that thing
when she tries to like stop him from
going by pointing a gun at him because
she doesn't want him to get her it's
like the best scenes of all time oh god
man and Seiko is just a total badass -
oh she is total badass but also has gets
that personality development
she's also martial artist so she has
great discipline so you know she's oh
you know if he didn't be loyal and treat
you right this is fun this one is not
good this is it so this good matchup but
it's like at the same time it's mm-hmm I
think faith is a great character I just
don't know if I didn't want her as a
waifu yeah it's it's bear it was like
that's what I'm saying like she has so
many qualities that you're just uh I
don't know she's the opposite of what
you'd want in a waifu but at the same
time wait y-you can't I feel like she's
one of those girls that like like you
fall for and then they like didn't ruin
your life but you'd still be like kind
of okay with it yeah I know exactly and
you'd love it
by the way ng in the chat asked if my
chair is $3.99 actually this is not the
PewDiePie chair however we do have the
PewDiePie chair but it's in goals ends
room my bro's room but we do have it
because it's [ __ ] pewter pathway but
can you do this
I can go pretty low guys I think anyways
I'm gonna watch it's uh I'm just gonna
vote for Seiko because I I just I think
she would be so loyal so about us and
she has that martial arts discipline I
feel like Dom would come in handy in
more ways than one but Fay is like that
girl that you'd be like you'd meet her
in real life and you're right just
I hate you but I love you sir just like
my brain is telling me to vote your own
hurt me my brain is telling me to vote
Seiko with you right now but my heart's
telling me Fay and I think I'm gonna go
with my heart on this one fair man I
can't I cannot be upset at all I feel
like I'm happy with any results with
this mashup though I am gonna end it off
with Seiko and I think a lot of the
reason like I said super disciplined
loyal super hot I think he beats you
treat you well but also if you've
noticed I have a thing for swords right
and like I've loaded Forza and you care
to the has a sword I always feel like I
like them I buy them
I feel like if I'm Mary or I'm they're
my waifu say are you Seiko she would be
like teach me some swordsmanship and I
would love that
yeah by the way I wonder what Ford would
say about your love for women with giant
phallic symbols mmm she the trap but
fair enough cycle moves on to the next
round but yeah man there's something
about failing like you said it well
Jordan it's like at the beginning you
think like yo that's not a good waifu
but then you're like this is just
something there yeah like you know
that's kind of something there all right
moving on to the round 2 and this is
gonna be crazy
we have albedo world's best yonder at
vs. c2 I'm gonna start this off I am
gonna go for albedo guys I'm gonna go
for a beta because c2 is great and she
has she's gone undergone a lot of
developments but I feel like
specifically with Lelouch is how she
developed
whereas with albedo I feel like you know
if she loves you she'll be into you no
matter what you don't have to be Lelouch
for her to love you so she would just be
a good amazing wife who no matter what
I'll tell you what anime that's twice
that you voted against C - no I didn't
you just what emotive that pours right
on no no I voted for C - in the first
round I just said zeroth words but ok
alright ok cuz I just say three strikes
and you're out because we all know CT is
gonna go there
around I vote see two best girl in all
of anime you think so Joe Hollis is a
better wife wouldn't see - let's be real
I forgot you both have [ __ ] tastes
Nevada is a better wife Lucy - all right
so I'll agree see two super wise but
like I don't know she's a little bit
boring for me I like more outgoing girls
like Alberto I'm sorry
I feel like albedo would like she would
make your night every night you know
what I mean
whereas she too would be like Oh tonight
I just feel like eating pizza but I'll
bet it would be like tonight I'll tell
you what false tears bring pain to
others while false smile brings pain to
oneself
see - we'll always be real with you no
matter what and albedo after that
initial lust of that he liked putting
himself good dried dies down like what
else is there see it can't die down cuz
you should actually an NPC character
that's a kind of actions have been what
else is there that no more death there I
don't I don't see any okay like what if
you were if you could be eyes with obey
at all
and if you could be Lelouch with c2 so
meaning that you are the guy the main
interest who do you think will treat you
better I feel like I'll beta will treat
you better
I'm I'm with the battle as well and I
think she thought her damn this might
this might ruin friendships right here
yeah see always you thought I feel bad
he didn't watch steins gate [ __ ] no
coast is not one my man ghost who every
for two years he just been posting see -
best girl see somebody just said albedo
will die for you though well here's the
thing see - you can't die like she can't
die for you I feel like c2 would die for
luge - she would if she could okay
I'll bet it would die for you but she's
so [ __ ] powerful regardless of
whatever role she's in like she was no
one that could touch her yeah both of
them are powerful that's true both of
them are very super human powerful but
yeah
albedo takes it I'm sorry anime dude
yeah
I'm sorry bro but you were here you
fought a good fight I tried I tried GG
no re boy yeah and and Briggs never
fails to impress me like I have no waifu
selections although his Todoroki hate is
ridiculous but otherwise he's fine dude
continue next up we have rin versus
darkness and yeah soon that iran great
not all darkness brawl darkness all the
way for me all the way what are you
thinking here Jordan I'm a pretty big
fan of darkness and like I said I've
never I haven't seen a ton of the face
series uh I'm also not a big tsundere
guy so I'm probably just go with
darkness I'm a pretty huge cinder a guy
not gonna lie but I'm also gonna go with
darkness in this specific scenario oh no
no Z Z enough phlegm still salty girl my
girl we're doing it I mean versus albedo
the power of the body pillow yeah and
that's the force of art my other cover
that I can't put on at the same time but
it's all better I have a better darkness
those are my particles when making you
decision next round remember who you
chose to have on the pillow oh yeah
because I was making a cool super video
but like I love obits oh my god next
round
okay so darkness and Obed are gonna be
the semi-finals on the left column
Twitter if you guys want to see the
brackets link is in the description
we have Balma versus yoko on this side
well I can't believe this
badasses so one is a like a fighting
badass the other one is like a science
badass so I think it's gonna be twice in
a row then I'm gonna vote for a
character that I voted against in the
first round like I voted for ears over
darkness but but because Erla ears I did
an advanced I voted for darkness and I
vote for Winry over Bulma but when we
did in advance and now I'm voting for
Baltimore versus Yoko boom was a way
better waifu in my opinion mm-hmm
anime dude hmm you mean I could
definitely point out a lot more things
about ball most character and they're
both talked here by the end of the
series whereas the beginning of stuff
there it's all a little bit short
oh my god
sorry Yoko I think I'm have to go with
Bulma like Yoko is probably hotter by
the in this series but bomas I don't
know bulma's more mature definitely uh I
don't know even even that though I think
Yoko is pretty mature by the end of
gurren lagaan yeah yeah I would probably
go for your code in this one even though
I like gold mom but you guys made me not
have to decide so I feel better also
then k hey or dent AJ says anime opera
having a mental breakdown over albedo
darkus yeah yes I don't know I feel like
I'm like I said boma I'm still like oh
they're so close I feel like when you
guys could change my mind if you just
argued hard enough but if you ain't
willing to fight I'm going with boma
well I'm with him all the way so I like
Yoko but she's a great character but not
necessarily you know the best waifu
especially since we don't see after the
series ends at the time skip and stuff
we don't really see her act in the role
of like a waifu right so we don't know
what she would be like as a white fool
yeah almost proven if a bulldog and you
own her family life right we see Boas
live so if she could deal with the gia
she could deal with anybody
we have muck City suit versus Eiko from
high school two dead again right away
Seiko soon that is great at all but
being just down for you is better than
sumit
even though in real life a lot of my
girlfriends have been soon and I'm like
oh she's she's being kind of like
distant now I love her more which sucks
but it sucks that you gotta love it
no yeah true but in the ideal world I
would just want like a martial arts
amazing beautiful disciplined loyal
Seiko
this is very hard for me because mica
stickers has always been one of my like
life who's ever since I've watched
steins gate but I think a lot of my like
love for her is because of like how much
I love Okabe
yeah and like their relationship is
awesome and I'm always have a sweet spot
for Cindy raised well
so I co can teach me how to [ __ ] use
swords pretty bad riveting I know but
okay so Anna me do do you know oh I know
we had to revisit this but I have not
seen Kate and psycho is a badass that my
god and Briggs is not mannish but I also
love a woman that could just mow down
zombies like no other with a sword like
that's hard to beat she [ __ ] to use a
wooden sword for half of it to brawl she
has matrix boobs yeah Plus that what can
those do in bed yeah she can move her
boobs and ways that no human cat the
hard choice then Jordan so I get your
vote is for Seiko because you're the
worst jjigae hasn't seen Stein get yeah
I'm a total pleb I'm just gonna Mac did
you already make a vote yes Aiko [ __ ]
dead but not steins gate I'm happy
either way cuz I'm so torn between the
two I think I would vote for me kiss
occur soon but it doesn't even matter
cool
so it's to one again like very tough
battles here and that's what I wanted
that's what I [ __ ] wanted people a
bracket that will make you squirm but
you will love every single waifu
so in these semi-finals on the right
we're going to have Seiko vs Bulma and
next up is the first time found that
darkness versus albedo I should we leave
this up wait okay wait Jordan who are
you voting for I want to leave this up
the animatic I know who I'm voting for
who are you voting for this I I want to
see you in pain this
he wants to see you squirm
well I'm voting for Alberto 100% like I
like darkness I think he's a funny
character
I think I'll bet it would be a hundred
percent better waifu see you guys are so
in love with albedo and angie thought it
I've voted for her in the first round
but after that like like I said there's
not too much depth there she's just uh
she's like crazy and love enough with
somebody to where she wants to like a
repo move that's phat that's about it
like she's just no extreme validates in
season three she like in for the first
two seasons he's crazy enough to do
anything for you okay it's not rape if
you like it if you're into it if in this
video I find he doesn't I would be like
yes baby I love you so for me it would
definitely not be rape because I would
be into her yeah I would be like and I
feel like ions like he's just kinda like
uncomfortable with it but like I would
be like yes baby that's let's go didn't
have a human body you're just a skeleton
yeah so it's like what happen to it if
you like down to do it and for me I
would definitely be done any time with
albedo I think we go with darkness I
don't know that's it stuff that I'm
gonna go with darkness I'll see you guys
are doing this yeah I mean you seem
pretty passionate a little bit uh so but
I'm also possible darkness guy guy guy
guy sensei oh right like you said how
better we'll do anything for you but you
can make darkness do anything for you if
you're just meeting cruel enough to her
about it and she be into it the thing is
this is wrong because I feel like
darkness in terms of her personality we
do get more nuance to it like we do get
more nuance where she actually is
resisting her family pressure and kind
of going off on her own she has that
sense of humor that I feel like albedo
doesn't
Oh on another aspect though if you're
talking about like a girl that could
like protect you
albedo could definitely do it way more
effectively and then dark is because
darkest isn't a great swordsman to say
the least a cars about to hit you
doctors throw their body in front of the
car dies yeah also how far would she
take Damascus because I would not be
down to like actually like hit her and
stuff
exactly I'm not into it yeah like I
would not like I think she's funny and
stuff but like if she was like you'll
actually hit me I'd like no see if you
say man that's not to me romantic or
like interesting I'm pretty vanilla to
be honest and everyone makes fun of me
for that but yeah like I just watch
swathi no life classic stop no no I'm
the same way but like you say that like
one of the things that Kosmas done that
like darkness enjoyed the most was like
tying her to the back of a freaking
wagon and just taking off so she can
take that she can take whatever else
that's that's extreme like I would not
feel good like abusing of chicken if she
says do it like I would not feel good
driver you think she is a she her
personality's more developed in albedo's
for now I mean the personality more
developed over your thought I'm still
voting for Alberto and Billy the
strawberry said I'm subscribing to
everyone who votes for darkness because
they are smartest thank you big ass but
when it comes to life is sometimes we
don't always think with your brain and I
even I literally have two body pillows
and it's these two characters you know
what Tyler I think it was Rio and in the
chat said it best he said he wants to
see you cry for voting against see - oh
man and like both of them are so hot to
me like you said Briggs you said
Alberto's hotter but I think both of
them are amazed they are both are maybe
I missed a into a growth ho horns you
know you really like phallic symbols and
chase
oh oh so this this was a fun rank of a
let's just call it a bay
there's no cop-outs here oh I guess just
from the the fact that if you know
depending on how far darkness masochism
goes like I would not be on board at
some point just on that fact I feel like
albedo beats her out and that is can be
a very significant thing right so just
based on that I have to go with albedo
but with the very hesitant heavy heart
because I love darkness personality
sense of humor background all that stuff
that fun coding mr. Z to not watch the
steins gate worst guy Oh
in a way I'm kind of happy the girl that
beat c2 is advancing but at the same
time Anna Maki do you really deserve to
have that body pillow with you right now
I have both body pillows Jordan yes but
you deserve to have the one that you
have with you right now because I want
the harem I don't want to just treat yes
I did in a day at least five darkness I
know better would be down darkest albedo
are in it Valletta isn't it Colin isn't
it c2 is not in it oh wow the fifth one
is probably Lisa Lisa who knew Lisa Lisa
Sparky I haven't seen jojo's yet right
the second semi-final connects a cold
versus ball na and as much as we've been
you know all supporting balm on
everything I think at this point it has
to break for me I have to go with sake
ho I feel like Seiko would be just like
such a dedicated awesome supportive wife
who whereas boma would definitely be
like uh someone that's hard to deal with
sometimes
so say goes for me the girl
what are you thinking here Jordan it's
rough cuz I like we've said before
almost proven like we've seen her in
that motherly wife role at the same time
psychos the type of chick that can kick
your ass make you like it kill a zombie
with a sword and then I don't look
beautiful while doing it this is rough
can we ask the chat is that is that a
thing
sure you can ask them to tell you what
they think but you know we can't pull
them you have to say your own thing but
yeah Charlie admitted you could always
you could do it why all kinds okay
you're just wrong damn so we're gonna
use the steins gate thing it gets me huh
I have not put it down until you watch
it Jordan I'm saving it for a special
time a special time aka tonight maybe
who are you going or bring quite a few
bomas and psychos in the chat no I want
to be split ID Jordan it's split uh
where's the coin I need to flip the coin
actually know what this is too important
to decide on a coin flip I'm gonna go
with boma then the stove's is taking
over
yeah guided to add a Mac with a K get it
right
I said bone was proven herself in that
role I'm a boma and I vote for psycho
how's that feel Jordan oh man anima dude
Rafi oh so I already knew I wasn't a
vote for psycho because rough outing for
you on the red carpet yeah you know what
some of these friendships are already
ruined when you guys see two so I'm not
worried about it anymore
but by the way Briggs did not have a
good time last aw it's true I [ __ ]
hated it man I'll and I'd left midstream
I'm still salty there's no one-piece
girls on here we had one last time
it cuz adamak made the list you know it
would be great a contact a contest
maybe after attack on Titan
but for devil fruit users or even just
characters they don't even have to have
a devil fruit yeah the only thing is I
feel like that would be better on my
yours or noxus challenges because I
don't make that many one piece videos
see we'll figure it out sure that's
definitely an option in the future so
who we got in the finals is the boma
versus no no okay it's a couple versus
all bad all the betrayal is I'm gonna go
psycho regardless of what Jordan voted I
didn't want to end it I wanted to make
him choose yes yeah I know because then
otherwise he's just oh oh and cycle this
is rough stuff because I feel like
darkness could have been in the finals
a lot of these could have been in situ
should should have been in the finals
for many people with for many competent
people for many men of culture if you
will I don't know man I feel like true
metal culture pick Valletta huh I do
love Valletta but I don't know treatment
of culture do not pick a melee over rim
not true for fake news find a losing
battle right here big news yeah yeah you
know oh man this is Ross because now I'm
thinking now I'm thinking with albedo
someone mentioned Chad before that she
is as an NPC she's kind of programmed to
love you right
so does that take away from her waifu
status or is it not matter is it just
like it's the real thing after day
become it becomes real and not just well
for on Zorro gown or gown have you want
to say it he that bothers him a lot
whenever he's input in those scenarios
he feels bad like conscious wise that he
programmed that in whatever that's not
how she was originally supposed to be
based on the person that created her
the way I see it she's superior to
normal female at women
I think Briggs just has a thing for
horns no but it is a question right it's
like if it bothers eyes and he's like oh
is she only into me because she's
programmed to be then if you're putting
yourself in his shoes would that bother
you like I would personally be like hey
you want you you want it I want it but
still I understand his conflict but like
you were singing about darkness and
albedo I think both of them would be
down for a harem so they don't have to
be your main girl you know Oh what
albedo is pretty jealous yeah about say
she'll kill whatever other girl you have
in the hair not if I order her not to
she still might behind your back or
something oh yeah that's a good question
that's a good question because this is
what we do on anime you two what we heat
we talk about the hypothetical fictional
woman being in a harem with us um what
do you think cycle would say if you said
Harrison High School the dead a long
time it's been a couple years I think
cycle would be less down an L better oh
but she's so like I feel like psych was
more pure right she's like almost like
she comes from this like disciplined
background she's got like honor and
integrity and she's like pure but
actually we learned in season three did
okay I was also virgin like pure is over
in it oh well I'm just gonna make it
simple for you guys I'm voting for Ella
Beto I don't think you had any doubt in
your mind I'm also probably a little bit
biased I'd marathoned like the first two
seasons of overlord like last week
yeah I've recently caught up to oh oh oh
my goodness oh this is a little bit less
anti-climatic than the darkness versus
albedo faceoff but I think I'm gonna go
with albedo too and just make a little
bit easier on anime ik okay thank you
thank you because I'm totally cool with
but like I'm getting in my mind I'm
getting like these real specifics now
it's like if I needed someone to pick me
out from from you know the game like
call me big like I don't know how to I'm
like okay
albedo wins fair and square both talk to
your wife who's god damn it Jordan so we
had to watch sidekick you gotta know
that you have to let him ask you man I
gotta make him struggle gotta make him
suffer boy oh I already did that enough
against darkness in the hood you know
bitter
no Anna Mack who would you choose I want
to hear your answer albedo versus psycho
well just because albedo is like my
top-five waifu when I think about it
I would probably go with albedo but I
feel like there is an appeal to cycle
kind of like with Fay like there's an
appeal to her that she's just kind of
like she might not be down for like a
harem but she's like she'd be down for
you you know she'd be like a quality
wife who like quality quality to the
point that you know you're like the real
world will never measure up man you hear
it you heard it here guys
psycho was not down for a harem so
animat kicked her to the curb like
that's how you decides who's in it is
whoever's down for it yeah well can
Indiana man world why not also someone's
like psycho better wins because she's
thick how you seen psycho man they are
both things but I would like to like
this is you we have us three here
especially me like you know sickness is
gonna be like in the finals it's gonna
be all sick yeah none of that light
speed said you know dassai an inferior
waifu and yandere could Alberto is kind
of a Andre but superior in every way
yeah she's a she's a she's like the
bestie on there in my opinion cuz she's
crazy for you in your nas it crazy
wants to like skin you a lot off your
dead I really did like you know though
even though
wasn't they I'm here at Nicky wasn't the
best anime like that but honestly you
know is the only you don't make that you
know what it was
right Nicky exactly what it was made it
somewhat watchable it was actually
alright well guys um we don't worry if
your wife who wasn't on this list we
will do more of these types of brackets
in the future cuz there's so many
quality I know my wife was like
obviously we only do 16 here cause the
way the stream would be too long but
yeah we're definitely gonna be doing
more wife was in the future
thank you all for enduring this trigger
fest with us I know you were triggered
so were we
okay but I think all these girls were
quality wife was that I chose so at
least respect me for that damn you and
don't forget to check out the Twitter
link in the description at an email for
the new contest create your own your own
attack on titan shifter we will be
winner will be getting a pro artist
bringing it to life and also if
everything goes well with the displayed
stuff you will be getting a copy of it
mailed to you if you choose to have it
physically an art to your character
which is I think an awesome thing so
yeah thank you for joining us thank you
Adam a dude and Briggs bro this was this
was fun like I don't know if we're still
friends hopefully like I'm friends
Briggs but like yeah we're going we
agreed mostly for this video yeah I
didn't disagree that much it shorted
other than the fact that he hasn't
watched steins gate
alright respect the fact that c2 is at
least on the list so I think I can put
stuff behind me of it yeah okay cuz yeah
because Jordan was really like C to
upset him a lot like to me C to him he
may be from Lelouch for his character
but not for me not for you boy that's
fair enough but yeah thank you guys
check out their channels links in the
description and yeah like was a lot of
fun next week we're gonna be on Knox's
Channel
probably for an cafe and then the week
after that we'll be back here for the
contest debating the contest winners the
top 16 bracket and who is going to win
the crate your own attack on titan
character contest so that's gonna be
really fun anything else you guys want
to say before we take our leave
praise the sun dress praise the sun
dress new video by anime dude
which is
why he was here because he is a true
connoisseur of the waifu's Briggs
anything to say actually I mentioned
that I'm actually finally uploading
another video on my channel it's gonna
be me looking at anime memes should be
fun okay cool yeah
and I believe your switches linked in
the description as well yes both your
white YouTube and twitch so yeah Thank
You Briggs thank your own in the chat
appreciate your support and
participation and triggered angry
comments Anna Mack is with a cave by the
way reading backwards and you understand
okay until next time see you space
cowboys bang